it certainly was true 15 years ago that
there were very few physicians the
United States who felt comfortable
taking care of tuberculosis patients
because TB had become quite uncommon and
then in the late 80s and early 90s when
it came back there was sort of a
resurgence of interest in TB even
historically it's an interesting medical
condition so much of the history
medicine actually flowed through
tuberculosis so people were interested
for that reason but most of our closest
patients are cared for in the public
sector and public health clinics one
certainly can't make a living taking
care of TB patients the same way you
could giving Botox or you know doing
weight-loss operations or things like
that but even more serious things like
cancer and heart disease are just
infinitely more common in the United
States and patients with TB as I
mentioned often or at the margins of
society often uninsured it's really in
general I think part of the public
health systems responsibility to care
for most of these patients
you